it is good to see soul sisters sitting
together we like this yeah
so i'll start with that because you did
say you said angelina was your soul
sister and that felt good to hear that
we don't get to hear that especially
about women in hollywood together a lot
so what makes her your soul sister i
don't think it has anything to do with
hollywood
that's why
we have some of the similar information
that comes to you when you work in this
business
but
um
what impressed me the most first about
well about valencia angelina that's why
was
her as a mother how much those kids love
this woman i mean the way they look at
her she's very patient
and
with the
[Laughter]
she's kids very patient and and very
strategic
very warm
and
fun fun fun fun fun thank you she's
always looking for things let's go to
and
this
i don't have that much energy so it was
really helpful to have her she's
completely lying she has all the energy
i know she's lying
you know what the deal we are both moms
and also there's the aspect of the mom
that's good with the kids and then the
mom that understands
then that motherhood is a cult you know
we have to help each other
we have to talk to each other
and it's very important to find those
moms that say yeah we are together in
this you know we can't get this done
and uh that was like a joy to work with
and then we have some of the same
interests we we made our time in our
lives where we just wanted two things
meaningfulness like friendships that
were meaningful not a thousand
and
joy
which is real joy and simple you know so
i think too with kids because we talked
about that too with kids our kids are
so aware of so much happening in the
world
and their and and also with covid and
also the stuff that we carry and deal
with and our kids feel so i think it is
we kind of came into our each other's
lives realizing also to be moms we have
to teach them joy and we have to kind of
lead in that space which isn't always
what you feel like
you know it isn't always it's certainly
not it's not how i walk around i'm a bit
heavy sometimes
it's the best way to do it but to kind
of find
help them
find that light and in a lot of the
darkness so
well i dig the fact that you guys can
lean on each other like that i love
hearing that and i know actually salma i
gave you a chance to really kind of gush
on her angelina you want to gush back oh
i would love
her well you know what also and this is
because i know we're talking about the
film so i can i'll do i'll do my little
segue but you know selma in this film is
the leader and a healer and a mother and
i we hadn't spent time together and she
came on i could tell as soon as she
walked in the room she just carries this
warmth and she just takes care of
everybody in the room that's who she is
and that that takes a lot out of you so
it takes a lot of strength and it takes
a very empathetic human being
so i think she also saw me
and i don't socialize very much and i
can kind of
be a bit heavy not unlike my character
and she has this warmth of it's going to
be okay and there's a scene in the film
which is that's very us
where and i think bonded us we're really
connected yeah well i know what i know
what's seen you're talking about that
scene and and to see that also between
two women right two women
just two strong individual women looking
at each other and being able to say like
it's going to be all right your love
like focused be here be here with me
um
we didn't know each other very well and
uh
and also
she was there for me every day because
she was there i was there for her and we
were not talking like oh sister no no
we just did it we were we just
first we did it then we started slowly
yeah not like oh we're going to be best
friends
we like justice oh no it was like an
organic thing that was
was real and the movie is magical in
that way i think yeah this film
there's something about this film that
creates
it built a lot of friendships yeah it
builds a lot of real relationships and
that's so important because the film as
i'm sure you'll mention is
so inclusive it's so diverse we are very
very different people coming together
with different experiences
and it was such a natural family and we
learned so much from each other
there is you know you even talked about
the fact that that you saw a lot of your
own family in you know the makeup the
diversity of it and so i wonder when you
look at that i mean how did that make
you feel to see your own family your
experience um reflected in this and even
even that theme of resiliency
in family
yes well it means a lot i mean to all of
to all of us and to all of our families
but it but it is true sometimes in my
family there's this film relates to this
child or this group is more it's very
rare that i am standing in a family
that
that i think oh
dawn reminds me of maddox and makari
reminds me of z and and has the similar
background and what i've learned within
my family we are stronger because we are
a diverse family that is what makes our
family
and and what we've learned from each
other and
i wouldn't want it any other way and and
i so i'm so happy that people around the
world will watch this film and i'm
hoping this is just the new norm yeah
and also
i was just thinking there's not that
many films that all of my kids and all
of us wanted to watch at the same time
right with so many choices now it's hard
to get together the family to watch a
movie
because they're at their different ages
and they want different things and this
is one of i was just realizing this yeah
this one is one we can all watch and we
can all love yeah absolutely by the way
what did the kids think what was the
review
honestly they all liked it yes yeah they
were they really liked it valentina
thinks it's the best superhero movie
she's ever seen oh i love it and she's
she's tough she stops she tells me oh
what were you oh she'll tell you what
she didn't like something oh she goes
what were you thinking
yes yes yes yes i've had a bit of that
yeah
but but this one they like this one
well i appreciate the conversation
ladies and i actually really just
appreciate hearing you two talk about
your love for each other that that makes
me really really happy and it's very
fair to start
on all the things go for it go for it
well no just the last thing is once
you're in the mcu you don't get out so
are we ready to do more
we were born granted we're born ready
both of us
challenge yeah
accepted
[Music]
[Music]
you